les managers de cette entreprise ce poste
je quitte
mon
travail de quatre ans aujourd'hui c'est moi sur le point
de quitter mon travail en entreprise
je suis sorti chercher ma
lettre de démission c'est un je suis désolé
pour ta carte perdue et il dit que c'est moi
toi  'tu me perds oh mon dieu mon patron est en
ligne en ce moment euh je vais envoyer un
message
attention à tous les
associés et gérants des acheteurs de Walmart Jimmy des
articles de sport Joseph le caissier Larry
de la
jardinerie vous êtes tous des pervers
et j'espère que vous ne le faites pas'  Je ne parlais pas à vos
filles comme vous me parlez
tout au long de la journée. Les managers étaient
encore plus impolis que d'habitude.
La journée ne se passait tout simplement pas bien sur le
chemin de la salle de repos. J'ai vu quelques gars
qui m'avaient harcelé tout au long de l'année
et un  la moitié de ce que j'avais été là
et ils m'ont dit bonjour
et ils ont juste fait leur petite salutation
qu'ils font normalement aux jeunes filles
et puis, vous savez, mes
émotions ont encore plus augmenté, alors
euh, j'étais comme si vous saviez ce que je
vais arrêter
maintenant  j'ai
arrêté
je suis absent
[Musique]
donc
c'est bon nous avons tous les deux pleuré
mais je l'ai fait et je lui ai dit la vérité sur la raison pour
laquelle j'arrête je suis juste heureux
je suis heureux de faire ça pour  moi-même, je ne
sais pas ce qui va arriver ensuite, j'ai une
peur bleue
mais je suis heureux et je suis excité, j'espère que
cela vous inspire, vous encourage ou vous donne simplement
une certaine motivation pour faire
quelque chose de similaire, euh, ou faire cette chose
que vous  Je pense à faire de la
musique depuis longtemps.
Je travaille depuis que j'ai 14 ans.
Donc
j'ai vu
le
fait d'arrêter de fumer, oh, c'est une si
mauvaise chose que tu dois trouver un travail dès que possible à
deux heures.
j'ai arrêté je suis dans un meilleur endroit
je n'ai pas besoin de ça
je pense que ce qui pousse les gens à arrêter comme ça,
c'est le désir de travailler pour
eux-mêmes ou d'être
meilleurs et de faire mieux pour eux-mêmes et
leur santé mentale et c'est en
quelque sorte pourquoi j'ai  je l'ai fait aussi, j'allais à
l'école et je travaillais
et vous savez, je faisais tellement de
choses et ma santé mentale n'était pas
du tout une priorité
et je pense qu'en étant sur les réseaux sociaux, vous
verrez que la santé mentale est une priorité et
les gens ont l'air tellement plus heureux, ils brillent
davantage
je me sens tellement soulagé, je me sens libre,
non pas parce que je détestais ce travail,
c'est juste que je suis prêt pour un
style de vie différent, j'ai l'impression que c'est le moment,
car un jour de plus
à reporter, cela signifie simplement
un jour plus tard.  je peux enfin consacrer 100 $
à l'entreprise de mes rêves
je suis nerveux
je pense que tout le monde doit
trouver
un endroit où il
peut arrêter avant de démissionner j'étais dans une
position où
je pouvais quitter mon travail je vivais en quelque sorte de
mon  j'ai économisé pendant quelques semaines
et je terminais mes études, donc
j'obtiendrais ma licence et commencerais à travailler et à
utiliser ma licence en cosmétologie.
Je pense que de plus en plus de gens vont commencer à
travailler pour eux-mêmes et se
donner la priorité, ils veulent
avoir un
travail qui prend soin d'eux.  mais
leur permet aussi de prendre soin d'eux-mêmes